your husband is a stuntman and he is I'm
told a very like he's big macho guy
right tall is easy he's like six five
and a half right um and yeah he's a
stuntman he's pretty hot and whatever
but he loves to sew ellipses oh yeah
which I guess is not that you know cuz
people don't think that being macho but
you know real men so yeah and that's how
they say it do I find that rose who so
that's like part that's like because
that's like Rose who so I want to run
into those guys in the Dark Knight make
his own clothes yeah well we have a
clothing line together
and yeah one day he walked into the
house and he's like you know what babe I
think I'm gonna get back into sewing and
I was like I know you was all really in
so now to get back into we would get
back in his gonna get back into the ring
i'ma get back in the sewing
yeah I'm like I didn't know you'd oh I'm
just calling me yeah he's got it so
that's how I our clothing line began but
he has a buddy who's another jock who my
husband was a perfect before he was a
stuntman he was professional decathlete
oh my god right impressive guy Yeah
right and so he's got a buddy who was a
professional skier so the two of them
they go they comes up they go surfing
they come back they crack crack open a
couple of beers and then they get to
sewing right while watching football
yeah I think my theory is I think real
macho guys it couldn't get away with
it's better it's like the counterbalance
wacho though you study six five he's a
stuntman cattle are there oh my god
Hades this Christ yeah I'm tall but I
look like a Danish woman you know
sorry
hate doesn't get you Idol I call that
guys tall I'd better stay out of his way
children pick fights with me I just I I
think that's cool I think it's cool that
he's doing that
you